[Music]
thank you
so this is the M2 Max MacBook Pro
let's talk about it
so this week Apple updated the 14 inch
and 16 inch MacBook Pros with a press
release and an 18 minute YouTube video
that featured a bunch of creators at the
beginning which was cool and then
basically a whole pre-recorded event
that kind of looked like it was cut out
of another event matter of fact it's
rumored that this basically was cut out
of an event that they were rumored to
have late last year honestly I buy it
like the URL and the file name of the
video had 2022 in them and the AR files
for the new laptops were compiled in
October 2022 suggesting that these
things were ready to go months ago but
whatever none of that matters what
matters is they're here now and what you
need to know is on the outside they're
basically identical but on the inside
instead of M1 Pro and M1 Max it's M2 Pro
and M2 Max
a couple other tiny improvements also so
the first Apple silicon MacBook Pros
when they came out in October 2021
honestly some of the most unanimously
well liked computers I have ever seen
they added back the ports they got rid
of the touch bar they brought back
magsafe they bumped up to an excellent
higher fresh rate mini LED display and
the performance is incredible like
across the board I don't think I've met
a single person who got one and was like
oh no I made a mistake with this one so
when you see a new one a year and a half
later there isn't really a ton that
we're expecting to change because the
big leap was from the Intel MacBook Pros
to the Apple silicon ones now we're back
to more incremental improvements so as
you can imagine yeah completely
identical on the outside same sizes same
colors the only way I can differentiate
this new one from my old 16-inch M1 Max
is the icon skin I've had on the back of
course Channel sponsor dbrand is already
selling these for the 2023 model so if
you want your laptop to look a little
different than every other MacBook Pro
world then yeah this is your best bet
link below so the bulk of what's new is
coming from the new chip inside M2 Pro
and M2 Max they are essentially the same
price tiers and configurations across
the board as before but apple is quoting
now 20 more CPU performance and 30
better GPU performance
um this in front of me here is a maxed
out M2 Max with the 38 core GPU and the
new maximum of 96 gigs of shared memory
shocker this thing rips so under the
hood it's built on a new second gen 5
nanometer process and they've added some
cores two more high efficiency CPU cores
and three more GPU cores on the pro so
it's a 19 core GPU on the M2 Pro and a
38 core GPU on the M2 Max also the
neural engine and media engine are
improved to handle machine learning and
media playback and transcoding even
faster than they already did if you're
into synthetic benchmarks I did Run
geekbench 5 and the single core score is
now the highest I've ever seen just over
2 000 while the multi-core score was
north of 15 000. here's some context to
give you an idea of how impressive these
numbers are and yes that is about the 20
CPU Improvement that we expected and
then incentive bench again it had a
chart topping single core score and
here's how the multi-core stacks up so
overall capabilities basically the
ceiling has been raised up by the 20 to
30 percent which is great but as I
mentioned in the original M1 max review
a year and a half ago it's not so much
about the raw processing power as much
as it's about the things that it allows
you to do better or faster than before
hence the name Pro theoretically so like
I noticed this in things where I have
parts of my workflow that work just
right with it so I have this thing I do
where I screen record with screenflow
and it'll do a full resolution screen
recording and then I'll export that and
use it and bring in a Final Cut Pro the
exporting of that screen recording into
prores 422 was dramatically improved
when we got the media Engine with apple
silicon so a 16 core Intel Mac Pro with
the Vega Pro 2 Duo that retailed for
over fifteen thousand dollars took a
three and a half minute screen recording
and churned that out in 56 seconds but
the M1 Max laptop did it in 32 seconds
so that was so sick that's one of those
things you instantly notice is way
faster this new M2 Max did it in 23
seconds so again a pretty substantial
Improvement like clearly the outgoing
machines weren't lacking but they've
taken basically everything that was good
about the old ones and improved it just
bumped it up a little bit which is sweet
for everyday daily non-demanding tasks
as you can probably imagine these are
still great totally great like I've
already told you all about the excellent
mini LED display that has a questionable
amount of light bleed but still looks
pretty great most of the time I've
already told you about the top-notch
design and all of the metal build
quality the huge track pad the high
quality headphone jack the return of the
built-in SD card slot I've already told
you about all that but what about those
other tiny improvements I mentioned
earlier that aren't the M2 Chip well
there's a couple things so first of all
the extra efficiency cores that I
mentioned earlier are great of course
for battery life not only is the battery
life still really good but there's also
a claimed extra hour on both the 14 inch
and 16 inch of battery I'm not seeing a
dramatic difference but hey the fact
that it's better at all
sick and then these laptops still fast
charge but there's also now a color
matching magsafe cable now this is a
slight difference since these laptops
are really only silver or slightly
darker silver but there you go it's
darker now with the space gray one it
matches color matching all the way up
until the white plastic USBC nub on the
other end and then there's a few other
capabilities Wi-Fi 6E Bluetooth 5.3 and
HDMI 2.1 so HDMI 2.1 was actually
something I was confused about missing
on the last version since it had been
out for a little bit but it's now here
and that allows for up to 8K 60fps
through one cable via that HDMI port so
that's about time Wi-Fi 6E is just sort
of starting to roll out now that's going
to be great for future proofing we
literally just got Wi-Fi 6E routers in
the studio for the first time and the
MacBook Pros have consistently been like
the fastest thing on our Wi-Fi network
and it continues to stretch that lead in
that department and Bluetooth 5.3 again
very much future proofing but that's
welcome but really the Apple silicon
transition has come a long way since the
very first M1 Max that we saw when I
first started doing this there are a lot
more well-optimized apps it's a lot more
obvious what the benefits are it's still
not complete of course because we don't
have a Mac Pro yet and also it kind of
feels like they forgot about the iMac
that's just chilling still stuck at M1
for some reason
um but really it's yeah these are these
are a level up from the rest and I think
my overall recommendations about what to
buy at certain spots in the lineup
basically stays the same so if you're
after battery life M2 Pro is going to be
awesome if you're after maximum power at
the expense of some of your battery life
then M2 Max is probably the move and
really my pretty textbook conclusion
here is these laptops aren't for people
who already have the M1 Pro and M1 Max
laptops that just came out they are for
people who have older laptops that now
have a better machine to upgrade to
unless you're one of a tiny fraction of
people who got the old ones and was
pushing it to its limits and just needs
that 30 more power in which case case
you know who you are matter of fact for
those people on older laptops I think
looking for sales now of the M1 Pro and
M1 Max when you start to find deals on
those
are going to be really good laptops now
you might have also seen the rumors that
it's possible that the first of the M3
laptops is going to be coming out later
this calendar year on a three nanometer
process you might be wondering if you
should wait for that to which I would
say you should actually wait till
quarter three of 2027 when we have the
m5s because that'll be 30 faster than
the m4s which is 30 faster than the M3s
and you can see where I'm going with
this like it's if you're gonna be
waiting for the next thing you'll just
be waiting forever because that's just
the way Tech is these are great machines
they're more than most people need and
uh if you can get your hands on the m1s
those are going to be really good for
most people too either way make sure you
get subscribed because I think I think
actually the new M2 Mac minis are a way
more interesting machine so stay tuned
for that video
also
um I said something
in in my last review but that being said
if the next version of this laptop still
has a notch this big and doesn't add
face ID
I'll wear socks and sandals for a day
like Linus like they they got to be
planning on putting it there eventually
right
well
all day today oh man my word thanks for
watching catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
thank you